*Musique*
Bienvenue à toutes et tous au webinaire anniversaire de Kobo célébrant nos dix ans d'impact et d'innovation menés par la communauté.
Ces dix dernières années, vous avez utilisé nos outils sur le terrain et nous avez aidés à créer quelque chose de meilleur année après année.
Ensemble, nous avons construit une communauté extraordinaire qui s'étend sur plus de deux cents pays.
Aujourd'hui, nous célébrons cette communauté et toutes les personnes présentes qui s'intéressent à notre travail.
Je suis Dev More et je serai votre hôte aujourd'hui. Voici notre programme.
Nous commencerons par notre parcours de dix ans, et Patrick partagera cette histoire.
Ensuite, Tino nous parlera de
récentes mises à jour et de l'avenir de la plateforme.
Puis nous parlerons de nos nouvelles offres, où je discuterai avec Ayman et Paula.
Après cela, nous aurons Tala de WHH et Sharon
de Save the Children qui partageront leur expérience avec la plateforme.
Et pour finir, nous aurons une session de questions-réponses où nous
répondrons à vos questions.
Commençons par le début avec Patrick, notre cofondateur et président.
Patrick, pourriez-vous nous parler de l'histoire de Kobo depuis ses débuts et du
parcours qui nous a menés jusqu'ici ? Bien sûr.
D'abord, merci Dev, et merci à toute l'équipe d'avoir organisé cet événement, et merci aux participant(e)s.
C'est formidable de voir autant de personnes
nous rejoindre pour discuter de notre passé et de notre avenir.
J'ai vraiment hâte d'échanger avec vous aujourd'hui.
Mais comme vous l'avez dit, regardons d'abord un peu en arrière avant de regarder vers l'avant.
Peu de gens savent que Kobo a en fait plus de dix ans.
Tout a commencé comme une idée quand
Phuong Pham, l'autre cofondatrice (et aussi mon épouse), et moi étions en Irak.
\[Inintelligible\]
Nous avions une idée simple. Ça semble évident aujourd'hui, mais pas à l'époque : demandons aux gens.
Nous avons commencé à utiliser des méthodes épidémiologiques traditionnelles pour évaluer
les opinions et perspectives des gens sur la reconstruction après la violence.
Mais ce faisant, nous avons réalisé qu'il fallait aller plus vite pour pouvoir agir.
Le temps entre la collecte de données et l'information des politiques est très, très court.
Il fallait donc aller plus vite et c'est ainsi que nous avons créé Kobo. Quelques années
plus tard, nous avons utilisé l'argent normalement prévu
pour les photocopies et la saisie pour créer le premier Kobo.
J'ai bien ri en revoyant ces photos
car ce que vous voyez en haut à droite, c'est le tout premier Kobo.
Ce n'est pas Android. Ni iPhone. Ça n'existait pas. C'est un téléphone Mio qui
utilisait une application Windows mobile.
C'est la toute première version de Kobo. Mais nous avons appris que ça fonctionnait, qu'il
était vraiment possible de collecter des données sur le terrain
d'une manière qui nous permettait d'aller plus vite.
Cette expérience de Kobo sur le terrain a donné son nom à Kobo.
Kobo signifie littéralement transfert. Il s'agissait de transférer les connaissances de l'expérience
des gens vers ceux qui agissent et construisent des projets.
L'étape suivante a eu lieu en République centrafricaine.
Ce que vous voyez à droite, c'est « l'hôtel Kobo ».
C'est littéralement une hutte où vous voyez ces chargeurs solaires et comment nous étions
sur le terrain sans connectivité, sans aucun accès
à l'électricité même, tout en collectant des données.
C'est là qu'on a réalisé qu'on tenait
quelque chose d'utile.
Des gens ont commencé à nous demander
s'ils pouvaient l'utiliser.
C'est ce qui nous a vraiment menés
à construire Kobo.
Ça a prouvé que ça marche dans
les pires conditions.
Alors comment avons-nous progressé ?
On a déployé en RDC, Ouganda, Liberia.
Les gens ont commencé à utiliser l'outil,
on l'a rendu public, open source.
On voulait en faire un bien mondial.
IRC et OCHA nous ont approchés.
Comment le rendre meilleur ? Plus pertinent
pour les acteurs humanitaires et
autres sur le terrain confrontés
aux mêmes défis
pour lesquels cet outil pourrait
être vraiment utile.
C'est là qu'en un an, on a travaillé
à lancer
la première plateforme mondiale telle
qu'elle existe aujourd'hui, avec des
standards ouverts, des formulaires accessibles
grâce à ce partenariat avec OCHA et IRC,
disponible mondialement via
notre serveur public.
C'est le point de départ du Kobo moderne.
Voilà les dix ans dont on parle.
Quelque chose d'incroyable s'est produit :
il a fallu un an pour atteindre le premier
million de soumissions, un an de plus
pour cinq millions, encore un an
pour vingt millions,
et maintenant on a atteint
un milliard de soumissions.
Le point important, c'est qu'on a grandi
avec des organisations comme la vôtre
pour comprendre comment améliorer
les outils et les rendre pertinents
et utiles pour les acteurs sur le terrain.
En 2019, ce qui était jusqu'alors un projet
mené par Phuong et moi depuis nos
universités à travers le temps et
différents lieux, on a créé une
une organisation à but non lucratif, Kobo,
qui héberge KoboToolbox et préserve cette vision originale.
La vision de fournir le meilleur outil, le plus accessible,
gratuit pour les organisations qui ont besoin de données pour avoir un impact.
Nous sommes fiers d'être reconnus comme un bien public numérique, encore plus fiers de voir
le nombre de participants à ce webinaire, et les statistiques d'utilisation sur le terrain.
C'est un parcours incroyable, porté par vous.
J'ai mentionné le milliard de soumissions. Dev a dit que nous opérons
ou avons des utilisatrices et utilisateurs qui exploitent Kobo
pour accroître leur impact dans tous les pays du monde.
Les statistiques sont claires. Elles parlent d'elles-mêmes.
Oui, nous avons de très grands utilisateurs qui nous aident à maintenir et à garantir
que nous pouvons continuer à offrir la plateforme gratuitement à la grande majorité de nos
utilisatrices et utilisateurs, qu'il s'agisse d'organisations communautaires, de petites ONG locales
pour qui, franchement, KoboToolbox est
la meilleure solution possible pour avoir un impact.
Ce n'est pas un gadget de dire que vous nous avez nommés.
C'est vraiment la communauté. C'est vraiment l'expérience, les partenaires en Ouganda qui nous ont donné
le nom, et c'est vraiment grâce au partenariat au fil
des années que nous sommes devenus la plateforme que nous sommes aujourd'hui.
Les fonctions, les besoins, la façon d'utiliser Kobo,
tout a été conçu par les utilisatrices et utilisateurs, pour eux, avec eux.
Et vous continuez à nous inspirer dans ce parcours.
Cela reste au cœur de ce dont nous allons parler ensuite : quelles sont les
priorités, quelles sont les directions que nous prenons.
C'est un moment critique car nous savons que ces systèmes, ces paysages d'information
sur lesquels nous comptons sont en train de disparaître.
Ils sont clairement menacés. Et en même temps, la réalité du paysage du financement
et des besoins croissants et de la complexité fait que les données sont plus critiques que jamais.
Moins nous avons de ressources, mieux nous devons
les allouer, et les données ont un rôle important à jouer dans cette fonction.
Nous voulons être votre partenaire pour nous assurer que nous ne construisons pas de systèmes
d'information descendants, mais que nous exploitons vraiment la communauté et des
systèmes d'information plus participatifs dans l'espace humanitaire.
En d'autres termes, nous voulons nous assurer que nous contribuons à cette capacité
de créer le changement du point de vue de la communauté, que vous en tant qu'acteurs sur le terrain ayez
l'autonomie et le pouvoir de créer ce changement.
J'espère que vous vous joindrez à nous et il y a différentes façons de le faire.
Le forum est un élément important où vous pouvez aider les nouveaux utilisateurs,
et nous apprécions vraiment tous ceux qui contribuent déjà à ce forum.
Vous pouvez partager vos leçons apprises. C'est incroyable. Nous avons appris de la pratique et nous voulons apprendre de vous.
Toutes vos idées sur de nouvelles fonctionnalités, des améliorations, la façon d'opérer, nous sommes très désireux de les entendre.
Nous voulons vous entendre. Nous voulons écouter votre expérience et vos opinions, et vous
devriez vous sentir libre de nous contacter avec des suggestions, des améliorations et en partageant votre expérience.
Nous sommes très, très désireux de le faire. Je le répète : « pour les utilisateurs, avec les utilisateurs », c'est pour moi
essentiel. Et « par les utilisateurs » car nous continuons à faire de la recherche, de la collecte de données et
à nous associer avec des organisations comme vous sur le terrain.
Je suis très fier qu'il y a quelques années, nous ayons commencé à déployer le programme d'ambassadeurs, qui est
vraiment une façon de reconnaître ces contributeurs sur le terrain qui s'entraident déjà
et qui responsabilisent ces acteurs dans leur
portée et leur soutien aux utilisatrices et utilisateurs de KoboToolbox.
Enfin, je dois bien sûr mentionner les partenaires Enterprise qui peuvent rejoindre une
communauté de pratique dédiée aux organisations de grande envergure
avec un déploiement étendu de la plateforme KoboToolbox.
Elles ont des besoins uniques et nous voulons les reconnaître et vraiment nous assurer
d'offrir le soutien et l'engagement à nos plus petits partenaires locaux
jusqu'à nos plus grands utilisateurs clés.
Encore une fois, je veux souligner que c'est essentiel pour l'avenir de Kobo.
Nous avons des nouvelles excitantes. Nous travaillons sur l'IA. Nous travaillons sur tant de fonctionnalités que
Tino et d'autres présenteront à l'avenir.
Mais c'est avec vous à l'esprit. C'est avec votre contribution, votre partenariat, et avec vous
qui guidez ces efforts à travers ces canaux.
J'espère donc que vous continuerez à faire partie de notre avenir.
À vous, Dev.
Génial. Merci beaucoup, Patrick. Merci de raconter notre histoire et de fournir
une vision si puissante de l'avenir que nous voulons créer avec notre merveilleuse communauté.
Avant de vous laisser partir, j'avais une petite question pour vous.
Quel est votre souvenir préféré au cours de ces vingt années chez Kobo ?
J'allais partir, et je dois m'excuser.
Je vais rejoindre un autre appel, mais je serai toujours dans la session Q&R. C'est une question difficile.
Il y en a tellement, depuis la création et le déploiement de Kobo.
Mais je dirais que je suis toujours très actif sur le terrain. Et quand je vais dans de petites
régions du nord de l'Irak ou en Éthiopie, et que les gens ne me connaissent pas vraiment ou ne m'associent pas à
Kobo (je n'ai jamais été promotionnel dans ce sens),
Ils viennent me voir et disent : « Vous savez, nous utilisons cet excellent outil.
Ça s'appelle KoboToolbox. Vous connaissez ?" En fait, oui, je connais.
Et c'est une expérience incroyable de voir
l'ampleur de la portée et l'utilité de l'outil.
Quelque chose qui a été créé parce que nous en avions besoin, pour pouvoir faire
ce type d'engagement, voir ce besoin et
ce service résonner avec tant de personnes dans le monde a été formidable.
Encore merci à toutes et tous de faire de Kobo le succès qu'il est aujourd'hui.
Merci, Patrick.
Avant de continuer et passer à la section suivante, nous allons lancer un rapide
sondage de trente secondes qui devrait apparaître sur votre écran.
Quand avez-vous utilisé KoboToolbox pour la première fois ?
Pour moi, c'était en 2017 quand quelqu'un
de l'IRC a insisté pour que je découvre le générateur de rapports de KoboToolbox pour son
intuitivité.
J'aimerais que vous puissiez voir ce que je vois, les chiffres qui arrivent en temps réel.
C'est fantastique. Des centaines de réponses déjà.
Oh, wow ! Tino : Nous sommes à plus de 50 %.
Très bien. Si vous n'avez pas encore voté, ajoutez rapidement votre vote au sondage.
Je réalise qu'en tant que panéliste, je ne peux pas voter, mais je choisirais
avant 2014, et je serais curieuse de savoir si quelqu'un a fait ça.
Ce serait incroyable car ce serait les tout premiers jours de Kobo.
Vous seriez surpris(e). Ok. Je vais terminer. Voici les résultats.
Très bien. Il semble que 2018-2019
soit le gagnant ici.
Non. En fait, l'année d'avant, 2020-2021.
Super. Ravi de voir un mélange d'utilisateurs de longue date et de nouveaux venus.
Passons à la section suivante
Très bien. J'aimerais accueillir
Tino, notre Directeur des opérations et de l'innovation.
Tino guide notre feuille de route produit
et l'équipe Kobo depuis de nombreuses années.
Il partagera avec nous des nouveautés passionnantes et nous donnera un aperçu de l'avenir de la plateforme.
À toi, Tino. Tino : Merci, Dev.
Merci Patrick. Et merci à toutes et tous d'être présent(e)s aujourd'hui. C'est vraiment fantastique d'avoir
un si grand groupe de la communauté Kobo.
Les dix dernières années de croissance et d'innovation de KoboToolbox ont été extrêmement passionnantes pour nous.
Et comme vous pouvez le voir, ce n'est pas seulement l'organisation qui a grandi, mais aussi nos utilisatrices et utilisateurs.
Nous avons maintenant plus d'un quart de million d'utilisatrices et utilisateurs actifs, ce qui est très gratifiant.
Nous atteignons un moment charnière, non seulement en raison de notre croissance en tant
qu'organisation, mais aussi grâce aux fonctionnalités à venir.
Mais d'abord, je veux prendre un moment pour discuter de certaines des nouveautés récentes dont
vous pouvez maintenant profiter et qui élargissent la façon dont vous utilisez Kobo pour collecter et analyser des données.
Vous en voyez déjà une ici. C'est l'une de nos nouveautés les plus attendues
de l'année dernière, surtout pour les grandes organisations.
Notre fonctionnalité Équipes permet essentiellement aux équipes et aux grandes organisations de
gérer de grands groupes de personnes faisant partie de leur équipe.
Vous pouvez inviter des collègues, gérer les membres de l'équipe et centraliser la gestion de données ainsi.
Et bien sûr, si quelqu'un quitte une équipe, vous pouvez le retirer et ainsi supprimer son accès.
Rejoindre une équipe fonctionne ainsi. Vous transférez les projets existants de l'utilisatrice ou utilisateur,
qui appartiennent alors à l'équipe, et tous les nouveaux projets, formulaires ou collectes de données
qu'ils créent à l'avenir appartiendront à l'équipe elle-même plutôt qu'à un utilisateur individuel.
C'est extrêmement utile car si quelqu'un quitte l'équipe, les propriétaires et administrateurs
auront toujours une visibilité et un contrôle complets sur les données
collectées au nom de l'organisation.
Pour l'instant, la fonctionnalité d'équipes est disponible via nos plans Teams et Enterprise, et bien sûr via nos serveurs privés.
Cela signifie aussi, et c'est très utile pour les grandes équipes, que vous avez un quota
partagé de soumissions et de stockage auquel toute l'équipe peut
accéder, au lieu d'avoir des quotas individuels.
Et je sais qu'Ayman en parlera un peu plus tard. Ensuite, nous
avons récemment déployé nos fonctionnalités de transcription et traduction automatiques pour tous nos utilisateurs.
Cela signifie que vous pouvez maintenant transformer vos réponses audio d'entretien.
L'audio est extrêmement utile pour collecter des réponses ouvertes dans vos enquêtes.
Vous pouvez les transcrire en texte dans de nombreuses langues. Et si nécessaire, vous pouvez
aussi traduire cette transcription dans plus de cent cinquante langues via traduction automatique.
Évidemment, la transcription et la traduction manuelles restent toujours possibles.
Et vous pouvez utiliser notre éditeur pour réviser et modifier les transcriptions ou traductions au besoin.
C'est extrêmement important car, bien sûr, les outils d'IA, comme toute technologie, peuvent faire des erreurs.
Nous vous encourageons donc toujours, et comme vous le voyez ici, nous vous obligeons à réviser avant
d'enregistrer la transcription. Ensuite, nous avons créé une fonctionnalité pour rendre possible non seulement
la transcription audio, mais aussi l'analyse qualitative.
Vous pouvez passer à la diapositive suivante. Nous avons rendu possible
l'analyse des données collectées de cette manière de façon bien plus efficace.
Nous avons déployé la fonctionnalité d'analyse qualitative il y a quelques mois.
Vous pouvez créer des méta-questions supplémentaires sur ces transcriptions d'entretiens ouverts,
puis attribuer des étiquettes, les catégoriser, les résumer,
les résumer, et tout ce dont vous avez besoin comme synthèse.
Cette fonctionnalité facilite énormément la réalisation d'enquêtes véritablement mixtes.
Vous pouvez combiner les avantages de la collecte électronique mobile rapide avec la
profondeur et la rigueur des données qualitatives.
Par exemple, vous pouvez facilement ajouter une ou plusieurs questions audio à votre enquête
pour enregistrer le pourquoi d'une question, ou pouvez-vous me donner
un exemple ou une anecdote pour ce type de données.
Vous pouvez combiner vos questions fermées, rapides,
à choix multiples avec ces données ouvertes bien plus facilement.
Cela signifie aussi que vous pouvez le faire sans quitter Kobo. Pas besoin de logiciels coûteux et complexes pour l'analyse qualitative.
Et après avoir collecté et analysé ainsi, ce que vous voyez dans l'interface ici,
cela fait partie du même tableau de données.
Vos exports, votre API - tout inclut déjà ces réponses.
Il vous suffit de télécharger, visualiser et analyser avec le reste
de votre jeu de données. Ensuite, il y a quelques mois, nous avons ajouté des fonctionnalités de suivi et de sécurité.
En fait, un bon nombre. Nous sommes très heureux de l'avoir fait, et nous sommes
très fiers d'avoir collaboré avec vous et le HCNUR sur ce sujet.
Cela nous permet de vous fournir les journaux de connexion à votre compte.
Si c'était quelqu'un d'autre que vous, peut-être un membre de votre équipe.
Vous pouvez voir exactement quand ils se sont connectés et d'où. Pour l'historique du projet, vous pouvez aussi voir
exactement quand quelqu'un a fait une modification, quand les données sont arrivées, quand les modifications ont été
apportées aux données, au formulaire, aux métadonnées du projet.
Tout cela est extrêmement utile, surtout si vous avez une grande équipe distribuée.
Si vous travaillez dans de nombreux endroits, vous voulez savoir qui a fait quelle modification.
Vous pouvez tout voir. Vous pouvez le télécharger. Vous pouvez l'exporter pour de nombreuses fins de conformité et
d'audit.
C'est extrêmement utile. Enfin, nous sommes ravis d'annoncer aujourd'hui que Kobo
sera officiellement certifié ISO 27001.
C'est extrêmement important pour de nombreuses organisations où il s'agit d'une exigence de conformité.
Pour celles et ceux qui ne connaissent pas cette norme, elle certifie
et garantit que Kobo suit toujours les normes internationales les plus élevées en matière de sécurité des données pour
protéger toutes les données privées : toutes
les données que vous collectez via vos enquêtes, et bien sûr, vos propres données personnelles également.
Voici donc toutes les fonctionnalités dont nous sommes le plus fiers ces derniers mois, et je pense
qu'elles feront une grande différence pour nos nombreux utilisateurs et organisations dans le monde.
Mais je suis encore plus enthousiaste à l'idée de vous montrer ce que nous préparons pour un avenir proche.
Pour commencer, les prochains mois verront le lancement
d'une fonctionnalité d'analyse par IA comme vous pouvez déjà le voir à l'écran.
Cette fonctionnalité vous permettra de répondre aux méta-questions que nous avons vues plus tôt sur
les transcriptions audio ouvertes de manière beaucoup plus efficace et rapide.
Cela signifie aussi, d'après notre expérience, que c'est plus fiable que de demander
à plusieurs analystes de données, analystes humains, de votre équipe de le faire pour vous.
Nos nouveaux modèles d'IA que nous entraînons à cet effet analyseront automatiquement la transcription
et répondront à toutes les questions pertinentes en quelques secondes.
Nous développons cette intégration selon les normes éthiques les plus élevées et en consultation avec nos partenaires et utilisateurs.
Nous concevons toujours cette fonctionnalité pour garantir qu'un humain reste dans la boucle.
Comme vous pouvez le voir, il y a un bouton, par exemple, pour vérifier les données.
Et si elles ne sont pas vérifiées, vous savez qu'elles proviennent uniquement d'un agent IA.
Cette fonctionnalité accélérera vraiment le processus. Par exemple, vous pourriez maintenant collecter
des centaines ou des milliers d'audios de réponses ouvertes et les analyser en une
en une seule journée ou matinée plutôt que de confier cela à de nombreuses
personnes pour transcrire et analyser sur plusieurs jours voire semaines. Ensuite,
notre grande initiative phare sur laquelle nous travaillons est notre créateur de formulaires alimenté par l'IA.
Cela intégrera pour la première fois un assistant IA qui vous aidera
à donner et recevoir des retours sur votre formulaire.
Pendant la conception de vos brouillons, vous obtiendrez des retours immédiats.
Vous pourrez aussi créer des questions d'enquête à partir de vos instructions.
Et bien sûr, nous ajoutons la possibilité d'importer vos indicateurs existants ou
documents d'orientation de votre organisation ou secteur.
Imaginez avoir un expert en enquêtes, un spécialiste des méthodes toujours à portée de main,
prêt à vous conseiller, à vous indiquer la meilleure façon de poser une question,
qui pourrait vous suggérer d'améliorer votre question de consentement, etc.
Nous entraînons cet agent IA. Nous en sommes aux premières étapes, mais nous l'entraînons à
être très prudent, non seulement pour être aussi éthique et fiable que
possible, mais aussi pour utiliser les bonnes orientations méthodologiques disponibles dans notre secteur.
Une fois disponible, je pense que cela fera une énorme différence pour nos secteurs
et le monde associatif pour créer de meilleures enquêtes beaucoup plus rapidement. Enfin, nous
travaillons à intégrer plus de fonctionnalités de gestion de cas dans Kobo.
Notre objectif est de vous permettre de suivre les bénéficiaires dans le temps et de faciliter la gestion des études longitudinales.
Nous avons écouté de nombreux utilisateurs qui nous ont dit qu'il est extrêmement important
que Kobo reste facile et intuitif à utiliser.
Nous faisons donc très attention en ajoutant ces fonctionnalités avancées pour ne pas
encombrer l'interface et ne pas compliquer l'utilisation en pratique.
Si vous souhaitez participer à notre recherche utilisateur sur cette fonctionnalité, nous serions ravis de vous entendre.
Faites-le nous savoir. Il y aura un questionnaire à la fin du webinaire.
Vous pouvez y ajouter vos coordonnées et cocher une case. Nous serions ravis
de vous avoir et d'en discuter davantage avec votre équipe.
Bien. Avant de repasser la parole à Dev, nous avons beaucoup prévu aujourd'hui.
J'ai un dernier appel. KoboToolbox a toujours été, comme Patrick l'a dit, porté par la communauté.
Nous dépendons vraiment de vous. Donc, si vous avez d'autres idées de nouvelles fonctionnalités, grandes ou petites,
des améliorations. J'en vois déjà certaines arriver aujourd'hui.
Mais c'est vraiment sur le Forum communautaire que nous voulons vous entendre.
Le Forum communautaire est fait pour partager des idées, voter sur les idées d'autres utilisatrices et utilisateurs.
Donc, s'il vous plaît, si ce n'est pas déjà fait, inscrivez-vous sur community.kobotoolbox.org,
créez un compte et partagez ce que vous avez en tête.
Et bien sûr, interagissez avec d'autres qui ont déjà publié des idées.
Vous pouvez voter pour elles, etc. Bien sûr, le forum est aussi excellent, comme Patrick l'a dit,
pour s'entraider, apprendre les uns des autres, et
cela fait aussi une énorme différence pour nos milliers d'utilisatrices et utilisateurs.
Donc merci à celles et ceux qui sont ici aujourd'hui et qui sont déjà très actifs.
Nos ambassadeurs et nos utilisatrices et utilisateurs experts de la communauté, nous vous aimons vraiment.
Donc merci de faire partie de cette communauté Kobo depuis quelques années. Et, oui, à toi, Dev.
Merci. Merci, Tino. Et merci pour tout le
travail qui a permis à la plateforme d'être ce qu'elle est aujourd'hui.
Je sais que beaucoup de membres de la communauté seront vraiment heureux
d'entendre ce qu'ils ont entendu aujourd'hui sur les capacités à venir.
Et je sais que notre équipe produit est vraiment enthousiaste à l'idée de travailler avec notre communauté
alors que nous développons ces capacités.
Avant de passer à la section suivante, j'avais une question pour toi.
Cela revient souvent, et je vois aussi
voir quelques questions dans ce sens.
Donc, j'ai pensé te poser la question.
Tu sais, la plateforme est connue pour son accessibilité, pour sa
simplicité et pour son intuitivité.
Alors que nous travaillons sur l'intégration de l'IA, comment penses-tu que cela
impactera la collecte de données sur le terrain ? Tino : C'est une excellente question, Dev.
Oui. Et rapidement, je pense que l'une des choses les plus importantes
pour nous et pour beaucoup de personnes ici aujourd'hui, c'est que Kobo est une plateforme gratuite.
Elle n'est pas seulement open source, mais nous voulons nous assurer qu'elle reste une plateforme gratuite en tant qu'organisation à but non lucratif.
Notre mission est de vous aider. Donc, le plus important est que nous nous concentrions sur notre offre principale :
Collecter des données de la manière la plus accessible possible dans les
limites, bien sûr, c'est quelque chose que nous ne changerons jamais.
Toutes ces nouvelles fonctionnalités d'IA, bien sûr, sont en plus.
Ce sont des choses supplémentaires avec lesquelles nous expérimentons. Et donc, oui, elles peuvent rendre la
création d'enquêtes un peu plus rapide et peut-être meilleure dans certains cas.
Elles peuvent rendre l'analyse plus rapide. Et donc ce sont des services ajoutés, et nous expérimentons
même d'autres façons de vous aider à utiliser l'IA pour poser des questions, etc.
Mais au final, nos racines sont très claires, et elles nous montrent que rien ne
remplacera un enquêteur humain qui peut faire des entretiens en face à face.
Euh, ce que nous pouvons faire, c'est rendre beaucoup d'autres processus un peu plus faciles, un peu plus rapides et plus efficaces.
Et que ce soit l'IA ou simplement d'autres améliorations logicielles, nous verrons toujours où
nous pouvons concentrer notre énergie. Eh bien, bon à savoir.
D'accord. Donc, avant de passer à la section suivante, nous aurons un autre sondage.
Et c'est quelle mise à jour de fonctionnalité
vous enthousiasme le plus.
Pas surprenant, l'IA suscite
beaucoup d'intérêt. Pour moi, c'est la gestion de cas hors ligne.
Notre secteur mérite une capacité de gestion de cas
à la fois simple et intuitive à configurer
Très bien.
Avons-nous les résultats ? Les voici.
Merci à toutes et tous d'avoir voté. Bien.
Sans surprise, l'analyse qualitative assistée par IA
arrive en tête, suivie de près par les transcriptions automatiques.
Excellent. Merci à toutes et tous. Il y aura un dernier sondage dans un instant.
Passons maintenant à la section suivante.
Très bien.
Dans cette section, nous parlerons avec Ayman, qui dirige nos partenariats, et
Paula, cheffe de projet dans notre équipe Services partenaires.
Elles nous présenteront nos dernières offres.
Ayman nous parlera des plans Teams et Enterprise,
et Paula des services partenaires.
Vous avez peut-être remarqué les mises à jour récentes du site web.
Nous avons travaillé dur pour recueillir vos retours et aligner
nos plans et services aux besoins variés de notre communauté.
Ces mises à jour sont le résultat de ce travail. J'aimerais maintenant
accueillir Ayman, qui nous parlera du plan Teams.
Bonjour Ayman. Ayman : Bonjour Dev. Dev : Ayman, j'aimerais connaître votre avis sur
l'origine du nouveau plan Teams. Ayman : Merci Dev.
Comme tu l'as mentionné, nos plans Community et Professional s'adressent aux utilisatrices et utilisateurs individuels.
Avec le plan Professional pour les grandes collectes, il y a eu une
évolution naturelle vers plus de collaboration, et nous avons répondu avec
l'offre Teams car plusieurs utilisateurs voulaient bénéficier d'un seul abonnement,
ce qui convient bien aux organisations.
Tous les projets et données appartiennent à l'équipe.
Donc, si un membre part, son travail reste accessible à l'équipe.
Bien sûr, il y a un quota plus élevé, six cent mille soumissions par an,
et un stockage illimité, partageable avec toute l'équipe.
Super ! Vous avez mentionné un quota plus élevé.
Pourriez-vous préciser ces chiffres ?
Et après, je suis curieux de savoir si des partenaires
veulent gérer plusieurs équipes,
comment devraient-ils considérer nos offres ? Oui.
Commençons par les quotas. Si vous vous abonnez au plan Teams
annuellement, vous obtenez six cent mille soumissions à
utiliser à tout moment durant l'année par tous les membres.
Il n'y a pas de quota assigné à un seul compte.
C'est assigné à toute l'équipe. Pour plusieurs équipes, je
pense que l'abonnement Teams inclut une équipe, et cette
équipe permet d'ajouter des équipes supplémentaires.
En ajoutant plus d'équipes, vous allez vers un usage organisationnel de la plateforme.
À ce stade, l'offre Enterprise pourrait mieux convenir
C'est une excellente transition
pour parler de nos deux offres Enterprise.
Ayman, j'aimerais que vous
comparer ces deux offres. Ayman : Bien sûr.
Nous avons deux offres Enterprise comme vous l'avez mentionné.
La première est l'offre Enterprise de base.
Elle comprend dix plans Teams intégrés à l'offre elle-même, et il n'y a pas
de limite de soumissions ou de stockage pour tous les membres de l'organisation.
Ensuite, nous avons le plan Enterprise Private Server, qui donne à nos partenaires leur propre serveur KoboToolbox dédié.
Il peut être hébergé dans vingt-cinq pays ou même sur votre propre infrastructure locale.
D'accord.
Juste pour que je comprenne bien, quand vous mentionnez
25 pays et infrastructure locale, disons qu'une grande organisation
comme CRS ou IRC ou Mercy Corps souhaite plusieurs
serveurs privés, disons un en Inde, un en Afrique du Sud.
Pourriez-vous le faire ?
Absolument. Oui. Comme je l'ai dit, nous avons un hébergement dans environ
25 pays, et nous avons des options d'hébergement dans notre cloud.
Et nous pouvons aussi le faire sur votre propre infrastructure.
Donc, oui, nous pouvons configurer les organisations de cette façon. Dev : Génial.
Merci. Et pourriez-vous aussi nous parler un peu de tous les différents
types de services dont bénéficient nos partenaires Enterprise ? Ayman : Oui.
Les offres Enterprise ne sont pas seulement un logiciel pour nous.
Fondamentalement, elles représentent un partenariat stratégique entre nous et le partenaire Enterprise.
Nous collaborons étroitement pour leur réussite.
Nos partenaires Enterprise ont accès à un gestionnaire de réussite client dédié.
Nous fournissons trente heures réservées pour des formations et consultations.
Ils ont un accès illimité à KoboToolbox Academy pour tout besoin d'intégration ou, vous
savez, former de nouveaux collaborateurs à KoboToolbox.
Cela inclut aussi un support prioritaire sous un jour ouvré
Et ce n'est qu'une partie des fonctionnalités.
Il y en a plus. Dev : Super.
Merci beaucoup, Ayman, d'avoir discuté avec nous. Et merci aussi à
toute l'équipe des partenariats d'achat pour leur excellent travail
auprès de nos partenaires et pour s'assurer que nos
offres répondent aux besoins variés de notre communauté.
Merci. De rien.
Maintenant, j'aimerais inviter Paula pour parler de nos Services Partenaires.
Bonjour, Paula. Bonjour, Dev. Bonjour à toutes et tous. Dev : Paula, vous avez un
parcours riche et fascinant en suivi-évaluation dans plusieurs pays.
Je suis curieux de savoir ce qui vous a poussée à
rejoindre l'équipe des Services Partenaires de Kobo.
Oui. J'ai travaillé avec Kobo pendant des années, et j'ai vu que beaucoup d'organisations dans le
monde n'utilisent pas Kobo à son plein potentiel.
On voit souvent des services très basiques, des analyses de données très basiques, et
la mission de cette équipe est justement d'accompagner et de tirer le meilleur de Kobo
Je vois.
Merci. Pourriez-vous nous en dire un peu plus sur comment concrètement les Services
Partenaires aident face à certains de ces défis que rencontrent nos partenaires ?
Oui. En travaillant directement avec les organisations qui travaillent directement avec
les communautés qui ont besoin de fonctionnalités ou de formulaires spécifiques, nous les aidons à
comprendre comment mieux utiliser Kobo et comment
améliorer ce qu'elles font, être plus efficaces et réduire les risques d'échec.
Notre équipe compte des praticiens S&E et des travailleurs humanitaires.
Nous avons des personnes ayant travaillé directement sur le terrain, donc la combinaison parfaite d'équipes travaillant
directement avec Kobo, qui ont l'expertise de Kobo, mais qui ont aussi travaillé
directement avec des communautés. Merci.
Pourriez-vous également partager
les différents types de services offerts par notre équipe de services partenaires ?
Oui, absolument. Comme Tino et Patrick l'ont mentionné, notre objectif est aussi de garder
Kobo abordable et aussi
d'avoir au cœur que nous sommes une organisation à but non lucratif, et c'est l'essence de ce que nous faisons.
Nous offrons aussi des services pour les grands utilisateurs et les partenaires.
Nous avons quatre grandes catégories. La première est le développement de formulaires.
Nous accompagnons les équipes dans la création d'enquêtes et, en général, l'utilisation de
KoboToolbox, puis le développement de tableaux de bord personnalisés,
la recherche et l'évaluation, ainsi que des solutions sur mesure.
Tous ces services sont adaptés aux besoins de
partenaires spécifiques. Dev : Super.
Merci. Je suis sûr que notre communauté aimerait entendre un exemple récent
de projet de services partenaires. Oui.
Nous travaillons avec le Bureau régional d'ONU Femmes
dans les États arabes avec ce projet que nous appelons TrackIt.
Donc, ce que nous faisons, c'est qu'ils travaillent dans la région avec plus de dix pays,
plus d'une centaine de partenaires de mise en œuvre, et ils ont
plus de huit projets qui ont été suivis avec le système.
Nous les aidons à créer les formulaires. Nous les aidons à créer le tableau de bord que vous voyez dans les images.
Et avec eux nous collaborons pour que l'accès aux données soit plus facile pour tous.
Et ce n'est pas seulement une case à cocher pour les bailleurs ou l'organisation,
mais aussi une opportunité de prendre de meilleures décisions basées sur les preuves collectées.
Merci.
Merci, Paula, d'avoir partagé
les différents types de services qu'offre notre équipe de services partenaires.
Et merci aussi pour tout le travail formidable que toi et ton équipe accomplissez. Très bien.
C'est l'heure de notre dernier sondage.
Ce sondage concerne les différentes échelles
auxquelles la communauté utilise la plateforme - des petites
ONG aux grandes ONG internationales, gérant des programmes à grande échelle.
Encore cinq secondes.
D'accord. La majorité a voté.
Terminons-le, et voici les résultats. Très bien.
Donc cinq cents à mille soumissions,
c'est là où se situe la plupart des gens.
Très bien. Merci à toutes et tous d'avoir participé. Et maintenant nous passons
à notre section Coup de projecteur sur la communauté, où nous avons Tala
de WHH qui parlera de
son expérience avec notre offre Teams, puis nous aurons Sharon
qui parlera de l'expérience de Save the
Children avec notre offre de serveur privé entreprise.
Nous commencerons donc avec Tala. Tala apporte plus de huit ans
d'expérience en suivi et évaluation principalement dans
la région du Moyen-Orient et de l'Afrique du Nord.
Elle a travaillé pour diverses organisations, du NRC
au CESVI, et maintenant chez WHH.
Tala se spécialise dans la conception de systèmes MEAL et le renforcement de la gestion
de l'information pour une programmation fondée sur des données probantes, et elle a également de l'expérience dans
différents domaines programmatiques, notamment l'habitat, les moyens de subsistance, l'éducation,
la protection et la nutrition avec un accent récent
sur les opérations en Palestine.
À vous, Tala. Tala : Merci beaucoup, Dev.
Merci de m'accueillir dans ce webinaire. Aujourd'hui, je vais partager notre
expérience avec l'utilisation de Kobo dans le contexte de Gaza, qui est un contexte d'urgence.
Dans le contexte de Gaza : Gaza, comme vous le savez toutes et tous,
fait face à l'une des crises humanitaires les plus graves.
Et au cours des deux dernières années, la situation s'est rapidement détériorée, avec des maisons,
des hôpitaux, des écoles, des infrastructures, gravement endommagés et détruits.
Il y a également eu des déplacements massifs et continus avec plus de 90 % de la population
déplacée et souvent plusieurs fois. Et la situation humanitaire s'est vraiment effondrée.
Cela a créé un environnement opérationnel complexe et à haut risque. Et
certains des défis opérationnels que nous rencontrons.
Pouvez-vous passer à la suivante ? Merci.
Certains des défis opérationnels que nous rencontrons incluent les restrictions d'accès et de mouvement
qui limitent vraiment notre capacité à atteindre les personnes dans le besoin.
Les bombardements continus posent également un risque sérieux pour notre personnel et les communautés que nous servons.
Et le déplacement constant ajoute une autre couche de complexité, rendant la prestation de services
instable. Les fournitures d'aide sont limitées, ce qui signifie que nous devons
continuellement vérifier, surveiller et prioriser nos services.
Et les besoins de la population évoluent constamment dans cet environnement, et avec cela à
nos systèmes de données doivent être adaptatifs, opportuns et transparents
pour guider notre réponse et maintenir la responsabilité et la confiance
Donc,
WHH travaille vraiment avec des partenaires locaux et notre réponse d'urgence s'est concentrée principalement
sur trois secteurs, notamment la nutrition et l'alimentation, l'abri et
les NFI, et le WASH. Suivant, s'il vous plaît.
Et compte tenu des réalités
avec lesquelles nous travaillons, Kobo est devenu essentiel à notre réponse.
Il nous a permis de surveiller les activités à distance, surtout quand l'accès direct est limité ou dangereux.
Il nous a aussi fourni des données opportunes et numérisées qui soutiennent notre prise de décision.
Et Kobo fonctionne de manière flexible, et le fait qu'il soit largement adopté
par nos partenaires locaux facilite notre travail.
Et, spécifiquement le plan Teams, a ajouté la structure
et l'évolutivité dont nous avons besoin pour maintenir nos opérations.
Donc, avec cela, nous avons pu adapter nos
flux de travail de données aux réalités sur le terrain.
Et cela a été particulièrement important pour nos activités de vérification et de surveillance,
où Kobo nous permet de collecter des données même dans les zones difficiles d'accès ou sans Internet.
L'évaluation rapide des besoins nous aide aussi à guider nos réponses d'urgence.
Et pour élargir notre réseau de partenaires locaux, Kobo a soutenu notre
processus de pré-évaluation pour les CBO. Parce que Kobo fonctionne hors ligne et sur
smartphones, il est accessible à nos équipes, nos partenaires, même dans les
conditions les plus difficiles. Le plan Teams
a apporté plusieurs avantages clés qui ont renforcé notre réponse.
Le premier est l'évolutivité. À mesure que nos projets s'étendent, nous pouvons faire évoluer nos
nos opérations sans perturber notre flux de travail existant.
Deuxièmement, cela a décentralisé la gestion de projet, ce qui nous permet d'héberger tous
nos projets sous un seul compte organisationnel et préserve les connaissances institutionnelles au sein de WHH.
Cela facilite également la coordination entre les bureaux pays et les équipes de terrain.
Le troisième point est la fonctionnalité de gestion d'équipe, qui permet un
contrôle d'accès basé sur les rôles et nous permet d'aligner les permissions avec notre structure de personnel.
Parce que nous avons des coordinateurs principaux, des consultants, des bénévoles
et des collecteurs de données, cela correspond parfaitement à notre structure.
Cela favorise non seulement la responsabilité, mais
protège également les données sensibles, surtout dans de telles conditions.
Le dernier point concerne le soutien renforcé de l'équipe Kobo
elle-même. Et peut-être,
pour finir de mon côté, quelques retours et réflexions sur l'utilisation de Kobo.
Les retours du terrain ont été généralement très positifs, et Kobo est perçu comme convivial,
pratique et donnant du pouvoir aux communautés locales.
Pour l'avenir, WHH souhaite capitaliser sur
le renforcement de la gestion d'équipe pour nous aider à créer un environnement plus structuré et sécurisé
pour la collecte de données et promouvoir la bibliothèque comme
espace centralisé pour les modèles et formulaires standardisés.
Merci, et je vous passe la parole, Dev. Dev : Merci, Tala.
Merci d'avoir pris le temps d'être ici et de partager
votre expérience sur
la plateforme et votre travail en cours à Gaza.
Merci beaucoup. Maintenant, Sharon va
partager l'expérience de Save the Children avec notre offre de serveur privé Enterprise
Sharon est une professionnelle du développement numérique.
Elle dirige les efforts visant à étendre et standardiser la collecte de données à l'échelle mondiale
au sein de Save the Children. Elle a de l'expérience de travail avec
des ONG locales et internationales, ainsi qu'en RSE et dans les initiatives d'éducation
numérique. Sharon utilise la technologie pour amplifier l'impact.
Elle détient un MSC en gestion du développement de la London School of Economics.
À vous, Sharon. Bienvenue !
Merci, Dev. Bonjour à toutes et tous. Je suis Sharon Sagues.
Je suis chef de produit associée pour la collecte de données numériques chez Save the Children International,
et je vais parler de notre parcours dans l'utilisation de KoboToolbox comme outil stratégique
à l'échelle de l'organisation pour la collecte de données dans nos programmes.
Save the Children travaille dans le monde entier, touchant des millions d'enfants chaque année.
Qu'il s'agisse de répondre aux urgences ou d'améliorer l'éducation, les données nous aident à comprendre ce qui
fonctionne, où nous devons nous améliorer et comment augmenter l'impact.
Avec des milliers de membres du personnel et de partenaires collectant des données, nous avions besoin d'outils sécurisés,
évolutifs et faciles à utiliser. Pourquoi ?
Parce qu'une collecte de données précise est essentielle pour identifier les activités qui offrent de meilleurs
résultats, nous permettant d'augmenter l'impact pour les enfants les plus
marginalisés et défavorisés.
Avant l'offre Enterprise de KoboToolbox, notre collecte de données faisait face à trois problèmes majeurs.
Premièrement, elle n'était pas sécurisée. Les données étaient stockées sur des ordinateurs portables ou dans des classeurs, et de nombreux outils utilisés
ne respectaient pas nos normes de protection des données. Deuxièmement, elle était inefficace.
Les équipes MEAL passaient des heures à traiter manuellement les données et à créer des enquêtes à partir de zéro avec peu
d'orientation sur les outils à utiliser. Troisièmement, nous avions des données de faible qualité.
Trop d'outils signifiaient que les données ne pouvaient pas être facilement partagées ou comparées.
Les formulaires papier étaient encore utilisés, et le manque de standardisation compliquait l'analyse.
Ces défis ont clairement montré qu'il nous fallait une solution sécurisée, évolutive et standardisée.
Qu'avons-nous fait ? En 2022, nous avons lancé notre instance privée Kobo
Enterprise, exclusive aux bureaux de Save the Children ; puis, nous avons déployé largement à partir de 2023.
Cela nous a donné un meilleur contrôle sur le stockage des données, l'accès à de nouvelles fonctionnalités et une meilleure gestion des données.
Nous avons accompagné le déploiement avec des guides d'intégration, la migration des données depuis les instances Kobo publiques,
une bibliothèque de formulaires basée sur les collections publiques,
et un support continu pour nos utilisatrices et utilisateurs.
Pour certains bureaux, il ne s'agissait pas seulement de passer d'anciens outils numériques, mais d'une
transition complète du papier vers la collecte numérique.
La transition n'a pas été facile, mais une forte coordination interne et une gouvernance claire nous ont aidés à surmonter ces obstacles.
Et en six mois, plus de 95 % de nos bureaux utilisaient notre instance KoboToolbox.
Aujourd'hui, elle est bien intégrée dans notre suivi et évaluation, et
nous avons des millions de soumissions annuelles pour le prouver.
Mais il n'y a pas de meilleure façon de l'exprimer que par les mots de nos collègues qui ont
souligné, par exemple, une amélioration de leurs pratiques de sécurité et de protection des données,
un gain de temps efficace, et une confiance accrue grâce à l'utilisation d'un outil standardisé.
Nous pouvons entendre certains d'entre eux dans la vidéo à venir.
Kobo est une plateforme magique qui fait gagner du temps.
Efficace. De notre côté, ce serait la sécurité et la confidentialité des données.
Donc, Kobo est en temps réel, convivial
Nous sommes fiers des progrès que nous avons réalisés jusqu'à présent.
Et bien que le travail soit loin d'être terminé, nous avons tiré des leçons clés en cours de route.
Du côté des « à faire », nous avons réussi à exploiter une réelle
demande de changement de nos bureaux pays, ce qui a aidé à créer une dynamique.
Nous avons aussi eu le soutien de parties prenantes clés, ce qui était crucial car avoir des champions au sommet
fait vraiment la différence. Nous avons fourni des communications claires et simples, à la fois au niveau mondial et pays
par pays, ce qui a aidé à maintenir l'alignement de toutes et tous. Nous nous sommes préparé(e)s autant que possible, mais nous
sommes resté(e)s flexibles pour nous adapter aux besoins de chaque bureau pays.
Ensuite, nous avons étendu les fonctionnalités existantes, par exemple, comme je l'ai mentionné, pour créer des
modèles partageables en travaillant avec notre communauté MEAL pour construire une bibliothèque organisationnelle de formulaires
de référence pour chacun de nos domaines thématiques. Du côté des « à ne pas faire » :
En tant que petite équipe de trois personnes, notre conseil rétrospectivement est de ne pas sous-estimer les ressources nécessaires.
Déployer une technologie à grande échelle nécessite des personnes dédiées et du temps.
Nous recommandons aussi de ne pas sous-estimer le rôle des partenaires locaux, qui peut varier considérablement, et
nous travaillons encore sur la meilleure façon de les atteindre toutes et tous.
Et pour nous, la tâche de migration était aussi plus importante que prévu, mais elle était essentielle pour une transition en douceur.
Et enfin, comme vous le savez, l'agrégation de données entre pays est complexe.
La numérisation via KoboToolbox et la création de formulaires standardisés ne sont que les premières
étapes pour construire un système de reporting organisationnel véritablement comparable
Voilà pour moi.
Merci de votre écoute. Reconnaissante de faire partie de cette communauté, et vive les données qui génèrent un vrai changement.
Merci, Dev. Je te rends l'antenne. Dev : Merci beaucoup, Sharon.
C'était fascinant d'entendre le parcours de Save the Children depuis l'utilisation
intensive de KoboToolbox dans les bureaux pays de manière décentralisée jusqu'à
maintenant, comment il est déployé de façon si organisée.
Merci beaucoup. Très bien.
Maintenant, nous allons prendre quelques questions de notre communauté.
Merci beaucoup pour toutes ces questions. Et, comme je l'ai mentionné, nous ferons de notre
mieux pour répondre à autant que possible.
Mais si nous ne pouvons pas répondre à votre question, nous vous contacterons
par e-mail. Sharon, la première
question est pour vous. Il semble y avoir beaucoup de
discussions dans la communauté sur comment les organisations qui adoptent
une plateforme, comme KoboToolbox au niveau centralisé,
comment parviennent-elles à la faire fonctionner
financièrement du point de vue de la refacturation
des frais aux utilisatrices et utilisateurs individuels ou aux bureaux pays ?
Pourriez-vous partager un peu comment
Save the Children gère cela ? Sharon : Bien sûr.
Oui. Nous divisons le coût de l'ensemble du
plan Enterprise entre les bureaux pays qui l'utilisent.
Et nous le faisons de manière équitable pour tous les bureaux pays.
Et oui, c'est refacturé, mais c'est un bien partagé, donc nous
partageons le coût. Dev : D'accord.
Merci. La prochaine
question est pour Tala.
Tala, vous avez mentionné qu'une grande partie de votre
travail se fait via des partenaires de mise en œuvre locaux. Y a-t-il des
leçons spécifiques que vous souhaitez partager
lorsque vous travaillez avec des partenaires locaux où tout le monde
utilise KoboToolbox ?
Oui. Merci. C'est une bonne question. En fait, nous essayons de capitaliser sur ce que
les partenaires ont et d'améliorer les systèmes qu'ils ont déjà,
pour ne rien leur imposer de nouveau.
D'une certaine manière, cela facilite aussi leur travail,
et le nôtre également.
Donc, la principale leçon apprise est vraiment de travailler avec ce qu'ils ont et d'améliorer les
systèmes qu'ils ont déjà, que ce soit en développant les
questionnaires ou en améliorant les questionnaires ou le flux de données et les liens entre
les outils et formulaires dans leur Kobo.
Merci. Compris. Merci.
Eh bien, il nous reste deux minutes. Nous prendrons donc une dernière question.
Tino, celle-ci est pour vous. Est-ce que Kobo travaille avec des agences gouvernementales ?
Disons qu'une agence gouvernementale gère un projet et souhaite avoir son propre
serveur KoboToolbox.
Oui ! Bien sûr. En fait, de nombreuses organisations et institutions gouvernementales le font déjà.
Dans de nombreux cas, elles collectent des données avec Kobo et décident ensuite pour des
raisons de souveraineté des données ou de conformité légale qu'elles ont besoin que les données soient sur leur propre serveur.
Et donc nous (je pense qu'Ayman l'a mentionné plus tôt) prenons en charge
235 pays différents où les données peuvent être hébergées localement dans nos différents centres de données.
Donc, si c'est une nécessité pour, franchement, des cas d'usage vastes et
complexes, qu'il s'agisse d'une agence gouvernementale ou d'une organisation, c'est certainement possible.
Et nous accompagnons ainsi plusieurs de ces grands ministères ou institutions.
*Musique*